[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ré
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
vous allez avoir
des musulmans donnant l'explication de
la population
te donne
Oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
a le sel
vérité d'évacuation
et à manger et peu à perdre
en conscience du pauvre basilio estime
Oui
tout
mais
sait ce que tu me dis
vidéo de baise et de désir
très bon et heureux juventis de jouer
que oui non
et après
sans dessins qui et angles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la disposition de l'état de santo tomas
la mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ton genre de crise
Et il l'a fait
tant que ça m'arrive
Oui
de l'activité
avant les péchés nous nous aimons
conditions de ce côté
connaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux
deuxième message de Sanz
[Applaudissements]
C'est de l'art
avec la décision
[Musique]
comme ça n'existe pas
mais quoi
et une partie de ça
[Musique]
à ce stade atteint seulement 117
Ceci est pour vous
[Musique]
déprimant était ok
pour tout le monde
[Musique]
ef
parce que c'est bon
c'est quelque chose de sympa
à ces passions et on garde trop
[Musique]
de chaque partie
Alors
[Musique]
à tous
de la pointe
[Applaudissements]
et avant
[Musique]
puis automatisé
regarde nous
pour décembre un soufflet
[Musique]
puis dites-leur de répéter
c'est pour moi
la fois
mais la vérité changera
de ce sujet
le salaire dans le système
MDR
diaz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oui oui
[Musique]
et
je ne sais pas
aussi pour servir
[Musique]
51 pour cent ce serait plus dans ces 200
parce que
est déjà appelée diagonales et la base de la
monsieur pas comme ça
[Musique]
Oui
Je ne sais pas comment sont faits les visiteurs
[Musique]
Oh
ou
mais non
[Musique]
il
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]